ça c'est quand même
à la réflexion je n'aurais pas tout le
dire c'est tellement idiot
bonsoir Raymond Devos je suis très
heureux de vous attraper comme ça dans
le cadre d'une grande tournée que vous
faites et que vous allez continuer en
Belgique en France et puis qui
s'arrêtera à un moment donné à l'Olympia
enfin qui s'arrêtera qui prendra une
pause à l'Olympia du 11 janvier au 27
février voilà donc vous faites la promo
bien en avance
on m'a dit qu'il fallait moi
personnellement je suis mais c'est assez
formidable quand même je me fais
connaître
je me fais connaître et reconnaître
parce que quand même il y a quelques
gens qui me connaissent quand même alors
je suis voilà alors je me présente et
puis bon je dis je suis de beau si on me
dit bien monsieur parler qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire c'est bien parce que il
y a des gens qui ont jamais la question
et les gens que jamais on leur dit
qu'est-ce que vous faites qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire cet hiver est-ce que
vous faites une tournure en tout cas moi
m'interroge alors quand je peux je
réponds si vous voulez m'interroger
alors vous donnez moi je suis pas le
premier à vous interroger vous donner
une très belle interview à notre
confrère de tes à nos confrères de
Télérama vous faites même la couverture
de Télérama va la voir un peu un peu
émacié
mais un peu compressé mais c'est ça me
va pas mal finalement et la danse
c'est-à-dire vous dites à un moment où
on vous interroge sur l'écriture de vos
textes il faut que je me méfie de
l'habiliter que j'ai peu un peu acquis
dans l'écriture de mes sketchs ça m'a
bien plu cette idée de ce métier de sa
propre habilité mais il me semble que ça
peut devenir un danger parce que ce qui
est formidable je veux dire
on écrit bien quand on ne pense pas trop
quand ça vient il faut que ce soit une
espèce de jeu de l'esprit il faut que
l'esprit s'amuse joue et si on réfléchit
trop ou trop vite on casse quelque chose
le jeu s'arrête et moi je me méfie
énormément parce que dès que c'est on
ne cristallise pas quelque chose qui
s'amuse comme ça qui tombe dans l'esprit
on fait de la littérature ce qu'on
appelle de la littérature c'est-à-dire
on écrit on soigne trop on fait on fait
du style je sais pas quoi mais c'est il
y a plus de vérité alors on va voir dès
que je sens ça j'arrête
on dit 100 fois sur le métier c'est pour
ça c'est que chaque fois qu'on se remet
à quelque chose on a une humeur
différente et on a une vision différente
de du thème que l'on traite et c'est
pour ça 100 fois sur le métier et puis
quand tout d'un coup bon on sent que ça
devient artificiel faut arrêter et
comment on sent que ça devient
artificiel
mais parce que c'est laborieux c'est
parce que on choisit des mots
on les ratures et puis on en met un
autre c'est pas très bon ça c'est pas
très bon signe si ce qui est bien c'est
que c'est quand les choses viennent
quand il y a une espèce de
je sais pas quand un mot on le sort par
exemple un mot juste il fait vibrer
toute la phrase
il est mort toute la phrase alors on le
sait tout de suite
c'est que la phrase devient c'est que je
vois qu'il disait qu'un très peut être
mort ou bien vivant ça se voit ça se
sent une phrase c'est pareil et quand
vous écrivez vous vous verbalisez vous
entendez
alors je désire pas trop qu'on me voit
parce que je vais je veux bien et je
parle de tout seul quoi mais c'est vrai
que j'invente beaucoup en parlant et
vous avez besoin de bouger
pas du tout à une table de travail
non c'est Google je veux dire quand la
source vient il faut la laisser vivre et
puis souvent c'est juste il y a rien à
toucher ah je sais pas comment ça un
thème une histoire je commence à le
développer et ça vient tout seul et puis
un moment ça s'arrête pourquoi pourquoi
quelque chose vous est donné et c'est
juste et puis tout d'un coup ça c'est
comme un robinet qui se ferme et puis il
faut attendre il faut attendre que ça
revienne ça c'est très déconcertant
parce que est-ce qu'il vous est arrivé
quelquefois d'avoir l'intuition que
c'était juste comme vous dites et puis
que le public sanctionne par une absence
de réaction sur scène et que d'un
certain point de vue votre oreille
parce que
c'est difficile de dire ça mais ou bien
vous savez
où vient vous savez comment dire
manipuler le rire ou bien vous ne savez
pas et moi quand j'écris une phrase je
sais si les drogues ou pas je le sais
évidemment après il faut que ce soit
ratifié par les gens et quelquefois on a
des déceptions mais en général non
des vérites ce sont des mécanismes alors
où on maîtrise ce mécanisme ou bien on
décrit n'importe quoi mais moi c'est
tellement logique c'est tellement
raisonné je ne peux pas me tromper
et pourtant vous dites le rire c'est une
erreur
oui c'est un peu violent comme mot je
dis cette
plongeant dans l'étude du rire c'était
on est dans une émission culturelle
c'est vrai c'est vrai alors je peux me
permettre de allez-y des obscures
[Rires]
non c'est pas c'est vrai que le rire le
phénomène comique c'est quand même une
erreur c'est une absurdité qui rentre
dans le con dans le conscient et s'il ne
devrait pas car il y a une logique de
l'absurde c'est-à-dire que si vous dites
à quelqu'un que ce que un rouge et vert
il va vous dire non il va dire non c'est
rouge c'est pas vert et bien le
phénomène comique c'est laisser passer
le vert pour un rouge
il y a donc une espèce de piège et ça
c'est la nature qui a nécessaire elle
aurait pu arrêter ça c'est quand même
une espèce de perfection quand même
les reins fonctionnent le cœur ça va
tout ça il y a et il y a cette espèce de
logique de l'absurde qui laisse filtrer
tout d'un coup c'est un peu compliqué
mais c'est quand même fabuleux parce
qu'une absurdité le comics c'était
absurdité qui rentre dans le sens du
sens de la conscience et mais a priori
elle est arrêtée par la logique est-ce
que vous comprenez bien ce que je dis
mesdames messieurs c'est très important
elle est arrêtée par la logique la
censure de la logique et bien pour que
cette absurdité rentre dans le champ de
la conscience il lui faut un masque
il faut un masque logique
et par ce truchement du masque
l'absurdité rentre dans le champ de la
conscience et
se répand à l'intérieur de la conscience
et tout devient d'ABS c'est-à-dire le
réel s'efface
alors on va aller plus loin tout de
suite c'est que la tension mais oui
parce que ça sent va dire il sait pas ce
qu'il dit
c'est que la tension qui qu'on a en soi
tout le temps simplement pour vivre pour
aller venir un espèce de tension cette
tension dans la mesure où le réel
s'efface est libéré
elle est inutile puisque
l'irréalité est en train à l'intérieur
de soi et cette tension s'évacue cette
énergie qui est libérée s'évacue en
faisant vibrer les muscles les plus
vulnérables qui sont les zygomatiques
voilà en gros mais vous vous rendez
compte de ce que c'est alors quand je
dis que c'est une erreur c'est que cette
logique de l'absur ne devrait jamais
rien laisser filtrer et pourtant elle a
laissé ça elle a laissé une petite
sourde porte ouverte c'est donc que
c'est nécessaire ça nous est nécessaire
il faut qu'on rit il faut qu'un certain
moment on quitte on oublie le réel sans
ça on pourrait peut-être la vie
deviendra insupportable à vous dire que
quand vous avez des moments merci
dans les moments de stress il faut que
vous sortiez de vous-même et que vous
dites à ce moment-là tout seul vos
textes en allemand
à la réflexion je n'aurais pas dû le
dire c'est tellement idiot mais c'est
vrai parce que il y a que ça qui fait
que j'oublie de penser je ne pense plus
à rien parce que je connais pas
l'allemand
vous suivez alors par exemple un texte
comme
l'horoscope par exemple je sais pas si
vous lisez l'horoscope moi je dis
horoscope tous les matins et bien moi je
l'ai traduit en allemand j'ai fait
traduire et je l'ai appris je vais
rester
et je le dis en allemand je sais à peu
près ce que je dis mais je connais pas
l'allemand alors c'est formidable tout à
coup de me raconte une histoire dans une
nuit étrangère quand même quel luxe
[Rires]
dans le quotidien du tout je suis même
plus dans mon pays c'est super je suis
ailleurs je suis en Allemagne
et j'ai dit les textes en allemand
devant des il y a pas il y a pas
longtemps
ils m'ont compris parce que en français
avant
vos textes étaient sortis en fait il y
avait 165 de vos sketch qui était qui
avait été publié matière à rire
l'intégrale chez Olivier Roland c'est
plus tout à fait l'intégrale parce qu'il
y en a d'autres qui ont suivi quand vous
quand vous vous rapportez à ces textes
imprimés il manque quelque chose
c'est-à-dire la voix est importante
parce que nous quand on lui prétend que
la voix manque oui enfin on entend ce
que c'est vrai les gens qui m'ont
entendu qu'ils m'ont vu
retrouve mon image ou mes gestes je sais
pas me retrouve physiquement mais il se
trouve que les gens qui ne m'ont pas vu
je dis ça parce que je crois que c'est
le secret du
succès de ce livre c'est que ces textes
qui ont été écrits pour être dit peuvent
être lu c'est une chance
c'est peut-être parce que c'est
peut-être au public que je le dois parce
que le public ratific quand même faut
pas exagérer je veux dire c'est fait je
fais je fais j'écris ma phrase et au
bout il y a un éclat de rire bon si le
clé l'éclateries rien c'est que le
comique c'est que ça marche ça
fonctionne et bien les gens il me semble
que les gens qui ne m'ont pas vu peuvent
accepter peut-être pas tous mais
certains textes
il vous arrivez de retirer des textes
vides de scène parce que ça répondait
pas à votre attente ou quelques très peu
franchement
quand j'ai un thème je le dis tout de
suite au public et je sais si il est
intéressant s'il y a un contenu si un
contenu je le travaille mais je le sais
tout de suite ça c'est comme les
aventuriers qui sentent qu'il y a
quelque chose à découvrir derrière
et raconter des histoires ça vous a pris
quand vous étiez tout petit
je me souviens que quand j'étais tout
gosse au collège pendant les récréations
je montais j'étais sur le Peron et je
racontais des histoires à mes petits
camarades qu'est-ce que je pouvais dire
j'ai commencé très tôt
et j'ai poursuivi
et ça m'est resté ce qui m'est resté
c'est les visages sont les gosses
qu'est-ce que je pouvais raconter j'en
sais rien et vous en êtes servis dans
votre vie personnelle par exemple je
sais pas pour séduire des femmes par
exemple
regardez moi
Raymond écouter
je crois que les femmes aiment bien les
gens
drôles enfin les gens qui les amusent
mais je ne pense pas que c'est par ça
que j'ai séduit des femmes
je pense que c'est par une chose un
champ personnel je suis désolé de vous
dire ça
c'est peut-être là mais je crois que je
fais comme tout le monde
je ne vais pas besoin de dire des textes
je n'arrête pas une femme dans la rue en
disant madame j'ai un texte à vous
raconter écouter asseyez-vous s'il vous
plaît je vais vous raconter une histoire
drôle non jamais pratiqué ce genre de
choses Dieu merci non non
ça suffit je sais pas un regard
une chanson
des chansons je crois que comment
ça oui
une femme dans ses bras et dans une
valse
en
disant des paroles
c'est ça c'est séduire ça c'est bien
mais mes textes
je lui dis quand il y a beaucoup de
monde
quand tu as suffisamment de gens dans la
salle je dis le texte moi j'avais écrit
un texte qui s'appelait suicide
spectaculaire j'aimais bien ça parce que
quelques fois on nous demande de faire
des choses suicidées et je j'avais
imaginé que mon attaché de presse venait
me voir en disant on parle pas c'est de
vous deux il faudrait quand même faire
hé j'ai une idée pour vous alimenter au
deuxième étage de la Tour Eiffel et vous
laissez ça vous allez sauter
et au dernier moment personne ne
m'arrête
alors j'ai fait attendre les gens qui
disent vas-y Raymond saute une seconde
en même temps on n'est pas prêter ça je
me souviens pas trop du texte c'est bien
c'est rien alors les pompiers ils sont
un bouchon ils sont en retard
et finalement je vais pour sauter et
j'entends quelqu'un qui selon à l'époque
c'était Fernand Raynaud et un moment au
moment où je vais sauter j'entends vas-y
Fernand
très brûlant quand même dans votre
spectacle le peigne on en parlait avant
avant l'émission érotique
non
c'est un défi je me suis plus trop parce
que je voulais un peu j'en ai tellement
écrit mais il me semble qu'à un moment
je deviens peigne c'est pas par quel
hasard je deviens peigne dès que je
deviens peigne c'est tout il y a qu'à
raconter mais c'est parce que il y a
qu'à mené la vie du peigne et une femme
me prend dans sa dans sa main elle me
présente ses cheveux et qu'elle
jouissance elle me met dans son sac
alors les odeurs de poudre de riz rouge
à lèvres c'est assez fabuleux une
sensualité c'est fou
alors là c'est vraiment c'est le bonheur
quoi
et vous êtes troublé quand vous faites
ce sketch
c'est vrai que c'est formidable si
j'étais pas troubler je pourrais pas
trouver les gens
je vais vous poser une question sur le
cinéma parce que vous vous en parlez
souvent l'admiration que vous portez à
Tati au grand comique aquitone Laurel et
Hardy et on vous avait vu dans pierre
fou et puis votre carrière
cinématographique n'a pas été
refusé sincèrement je veux dire je n'ai
pas pourquoi si je fais pas de cinéma
c'est pas parce qu'on me demande pas
c'est parce que
je trouve que c'est difficile de dire ça
à la télévision
que l'image ne suggère rien
on vous montre une image qui a été
choisie par quelqu'un excusez-moi
je vais vous choquer mais je le pense je
dis pas que c'est pas
septième art tout de même j'en tiens
compte
mais quelqu'un
la vision de quelque chose il vous la
montre vous la recevez vous la recevez
pas vous ne pouvez pas intervenir
tandis que par l'autruchement des mots
vous suggérez vous déclencher des images
dans la tête des gens c'est bien que les
gens font leurs images ils participent
ils ont une vie
tandis que l'image voilà c'est ça ah
c'est bien c'est pas bien
la preuve c'est que ça se déroule alors
il y a des chefs
mais
n'importe dans n'importe quoi une image
succède à une autre on regarde quelques
fonds sans même pas compte aussi un peu
endormi vous savez on crois que c'est la
même chose c'est le même film les gars
il y a beaucoup trop d'images vous avez
raison
d'images
et puis quand c'est fait par un très
grand artiste c'est sublime mais c'est
pas toujours fait la quantité de mettre
de pellicule qui ont été tournés
je suis allé très loin je suis passé je
peux me lever mais oui justement
je passe à travers un mur je peux dire
que je passe à travers un mur si je
donne une bonne explication
un trou de serrure ça m'a quand même
intrigué alors je regarde et qu'est-ce
que je vois de l'autre côté du mur mon
oeil qui était passé de l'autre côté je
sais pas possible j'enfonce mon doigt je
me fous dans l’œil
alors je peux expliquer pourquoi je
fasse à travers un mur je me trouve de
l'autre côté ça je peux le dire je vous
montrer si c'est la peinture c'est comme
de la peinture je veux pas le montrer ou
alors on va dire il y a un truc
vous avez une image mentale quand même
quand vous passez à travers le mur vous
êtes et dans le surréaliste et parce que
si le pouvoir du texte le pouvoir des
mots
les mots évoquent l'évocation c'est
fantastique enfin
encore une fois moi je ne fais pas autre
chose je vais raconter quand même
histoire du si vous le permettez du
chien pour montrer comment on rentre on
part du quotidien pour rentrer dans le
dans l'imaginaire
dans la rue avec mon chien
on est dans le quotidien
je rencontre une dame avec sa petite
fille
et j'entends la dame qui dit à sa petite
fille va caresser le chien et la petite
fille est venue me caresser la main
parce que là tout est normal
il y a erreur sur la personne que le
chien c'est l'autre mais la petite fille
a continué à me caresser gentiment la
main et la dame a dit tu vois qu'il est
pas méchant
et on est passé dans l'imagerie ça y est
et mon chien lui hydrate jamais une
occasion de se taire à cru avant
d'ajouter et ne lui manque que la parole
ça vous étonne quand même ça vous étonne
bah moi ce qui m'a le plus étonné
c'est que c'est pas que c'est dans mes
prix pour un chien tout le monde peut se
tromper mais qu'elle n'est pas été
autrement surprise dans le temps de mon
chien parler alors
les gens plus de rien etc ils savent pas
c'est fini on bascule
c'est pas des mots
fier de trois mots pièges que tout d'un
coup on passe du du réel dans
l'imaginaire
[Musique]